[Musique]
demain soir vous offrirez probablement
des cadeaux à vos proches et si vos
proches sont un peu des gros relou vous
serez peut-être anxieux au moment où ils
ouvriront vos cadeaux vous vous
demanderez sans doute si vous avez bien
choisi ses cadeaux avez-vous offert deux
cadeaux de noël optimales alors à priori
à la notion de cadeaux optimale est très
simple imaginons que doivent offrir un
cadeau au monstre vert de thibault et
que j'hésite entre disons nature secrète
de patrick boos et pierre karner le
théorème du parapluie de michael launay
et je ne sais pas ce qui aura un autre
livre de youtuber scientifique sorti
récemment et qu'on pourrait offrir à
noël
[Musique]
ah oui tiens il ya ce livre sorti le
fabuleux chantier par le mec de saint
paul puis bon faut que je fasse tout le
tralala cette vidéo n'est pas un
placement de produit pour patrick
pierrot michael bon par contre le mec de
senso roll m'a bel et bien harcelé pour
que je casse en garde
bref revenons au monstre vert donc je
veux lui offrir un cadeau mais j'hésite
entre ces trois livres lequel ils
doivent offrir
lequel des trois est le cadeau optimale
alors oui il ya une réponse assez
triviale il suffit de donner au monstre
vert le livre qui lui plaira le plus et
bien sûr toute la difficulté d'offrir
des cadeaux ou de prendre des décisions
de façon plus générale c'est bien
entendu le fait qu'on ne sait pas a
priori ce qui plaira le plus d'encre cas
où monstre vert il nous faut donc
prendre une décision dans l'incertitude
avant de savoir parfaitement toutes les
données du problème
j'insiste un peu dessus parce que c'est
si facile de dire après coup ah mince
oui bien sûr j'aurais dû faire ça mais
ce n'est généralement pas la bonne façon
de raisonner en effet en raisonnant
après coup on risque fort de tomber dans
le piège du bief rétrospectif ou and
night by us en anglais qui consiste à
sous-estimé la difficulté de la prise de
décision avant qu'on n'en connaisse
l'issue ce biais rétrospectif et
particulièrement horrible quand il
s'agit de juger après coup la décision
de quelqu'un d'autre
typiquement quand un politicien choisi
de faire x et qu'il se trouve que
l'implémentation de x conduit à des
catastrophes c'est si facile et tentant
de penser que le politicien en question
est idiot
ou de juste conclure qu'il n'aurait pas
dû faire ce qu'il a fait combien de
footeux affirme après coup l'entraîneur
il aurait pas dû titulariser tel ou tel
joueur ou encore très élevé des villes
n'auraient pas dû tirer en force
combien d'entre vous ont déjà 10 de vos
amis qui n'auraient clairement jamais dû
poser leur démission ou qu'il n'aurait
pas dû se marier ou qu'il n'aurait pas
dû offrir tel ou tel cadeau à telle
personne
ça peut sembler très facile de juger une
prise de décision après coup mais c'est
un peu de la triche
car on connaît déjà les conséquences de
la décision sauf qu'en fait ce n'est pas
si simple
notamment car il faut encore réussir à
prédire le contrefactuelle c'est à dire
ce qu'il se serait passé si la décision
était autre mais surtout ça vous donne
l'illusion souvent erroné de penser que
vous auriez pu prédire les conséquences
de la décision au moment de la prise de
décision sauf que faire des prédictions
c'est en fait très difficile surtout
concernant le futur
pour éviter ce piège du bief
rétrospectif il est crucial de se
demander ce que la personne savait au
moment de la prise de décision ou plus
exactement
sachant ce que la personne a observé
avant sa prise de décision
quels étaient les croyances les plus
légitimes à avoir qu'aurait-il fallu
penser et avec quelle incertitudes et du
coup quelle aurait été la prise de
décisions optimales au moment de la
prise de décision au moment où trezeguet
a posé le ballon sur le point de penalty
etait-il optimale pour lui de préférer
un tir en lucarne en puissance à la
rentrée 2010 8 était-il optimale pour
mieux suffit de se lancer à temps plein
sur youtube avant la crise des gilets
jaunes
etait-il optimale pour le premier
ministre edouard philippe d'accélérer la
mise en place de la taxe carbone sur le
fuel le gaz naturel le diesel et
l'essence est aujourd'hui le 23 décembre
quel est le livre optimale à offrir aux
monstres verts
le problème comme vous l'aurez compris
c'est qu'on ne sait pas quel livre
plaira le plus au monstre vert cependant
on n'est pas complètement ignorants non
plus au sujet du monstre vert pour
commencer on sait que c'est un monstre
vert donc a priori il devrait apprécier
des images d'autres monstres de la
nature il semble même complètement
improbable qu'ils détestent nature
secrète
je veux dire vous avez vu à quel point
ce livre est magnifique clairement c'est
un succès garanti
cependant on sait d'autre chose sur le
monstre vert on sait qu'il a un ami
appelé
et monsieur fille et que monsieur filles
aiment bien les maths et pour ceux qui
en douteraient voici un petit extra de
monsieur fils qui parle de mad
j'aime les maths parce que tout en étant
la plus rigoureuse c'est aussi la
science la plus libre en ceci que c'est
la seule qui n'est pas contrainte par le
réel n'a pas d'autre objet d'étude que
ce qu'elle se crée elle même à travers
des actions des règles des définitions
les objets mathématiques surgissent de
là comme par magie et ça quelque chose
de génial et donc le livre de michel
donnet risque de vraiment plaire au
monstre vert bien sûr ça reste des
matches et il ne semble pas improbable
que le monstre vert préfère ne pas y
être exposé mais ça semble tout de même
très peu probable ainsi le monstre vert
va très probablement fortement apprécié
le théorème du parapluie
d'autant que le livre est absolument
génial y compris pour des personnes a
priori allergique aux maths
ce livre est donc un grand succès quasi
garantie même si un tout petit risque
que le monstre vert soit en fait un poil
déçu au moment de recevoir encore un
livre de matt
enfin il ya le fabuleux chantier et je
veux pas dire mais à l'exception de
monsieur fi sync for l'éclairement le
youtuber préféré du monstre vert ou du
cndd forum est clairement le du tueur
avec qui le monstre vert a fait le plus
de collabo clairement le monstre vert ne
me détestent pas par ailleurs le monstre
vert à l'air d'adorer la philosophie
monsieur fille le pass in de philo à
longueur de journée et le monstre vert
ne s'est toujours pas enfui or des trois
livres le fabuleux chantier est
clairement celui qui contient le plus de
philo avec notamment un chapitre 16 qui
s'appelle même philosophie morale
calculable et donc monsieur fille a même
dit du bien
donc j'ai envie de dire qu'il ya une
bonne probabilité que le monstre vert
trouve le fabuleux chantier absolument
officines cependant là pour le coup il
semble aussi avoir un risque assez
important de fait il même s'il semble
probable que le monstre vert adore le
fabuleux chantier il semble tout de même
assez probable qu'ils soient en fait
vraiment déçu par ce cadeau voire
peut-être qu'ils sont un peu en mode
vénère au moment de recevoir ce cadeau
après tout c'est noël et des trois
livres c'est clairement le moins joviale
voilà on a fait l'analyse bayésienne du
problème ou vient d'estimer les
probabilités de conséquence de chacune
des prises de décision soit on y va avec
nature secrète qui est un succès garanti
soit avec le théorème du parapluie
grand succès très probable disons à 90%
mais avec un léger risque deux succès
seulement mitigés si on y va avec le
fabuleux chantier avec explosion de joie
possible avec probabilité 60% mais aussi
un certain risque d' immense déception
pour le monstre vert avec disons
probabilité 40%
ok j'ai fait l'analyse bay viennent que
dois-je faire et bien c'est là que
techniquement on va devoir sortir un peu
du cadre du mécanisme pour aller vers
celui de la théorie de la prise de
décisions statistiques qui en gros et la
même chose que le conséquent racialisme
moral ce qu'on va faire c'est quantifier
les différentes issues possibles selon
notre jugement de ceux qui est désirable
ainsi je vais peut-être considérer qu'un
succès vaut 5 point qu'un grand succès
envoie aux 7es qu'une explosion de joie
vaut 10 points tandis qu'un succès
seulement mitigés correspond à deux
points et une déception à -10 points
ensuite on va calculer ce qu'on appelle
l'espérance de points de chaque décision
qui est la moyenne des points obtenus
sur l'ensemble des scénarios futurs
probables pour nature secrète ça nous
fait cinq points dans tous les cas donc
l'espérance de points est égal à 5
points pour le théorème du parapluie
ça nous fait sept points avec
probabilité 90 % +2 points avec
probabilité 10% en tapant les opérations
dans une calculatrice j'obtiens une
espérance de points égal à 6,5 et ça
correspond bien en fait que en gros ça
va être très probablement sept points
mais que ça sera possiblement deux
points ce qui nous ramène un petit peu
en dessous de 7 points
enfin pour le fabuleux chantier ça nous
fait dix points avec probabilité 60%
mais aussi moins 10 points avec
probabilité 40% ce qui nous fait une
espérance de points égal 1 2 point
la solution avec la meilleure espérance
de points est alors le théorème du
parapluie en l'état actuel de nos
connaissances c'est donc le cadeau
optimale à offrir aux monstres au vert
alors je quand même finir sur deux
remarques avant de conclure cette vidéo
la première c'est qu'on peut démontrer
que cette approche qui consiste à noter
les différentes conséquences et ensuite
calculer les espérances de points ce
qu'on pourra du coup appelé le
conséquentialiste bayésiens et bien
cette approche est en fait la seule
approche de prise de décisions qui
soient cohérentes et compatible avec le
raisonnement probabiliste ceci est en
effet un théorème appelé théorème de
vollmann morgenstern dont on a
d'ailleurs déjà parlé dans une vidéo de
la série sur la démocratie et du coup si
vous êtes vraiment bayésiens alors le
conséquentialiste bayésiens devrait sans
doute être votre approche pour toutes
les prises de décision même si au
passage clairement il ya une sacrée
difficultés au moment de donner des
notes à chacune des issues imaginables
et d'ailleurs cette difficulté est
vraiment l'objet du fabuleux chantier
autre remarque en pratique on a souvent
un délai entre la réflexion sur la
décision et la prise de décision si on
veut optimiser la prise de décisions
d'état lors crucial de profiter de ce
délai pour réduire notre incertitudes
sur les issues possibles
typiquement dans notre cas la plus
grosse incertitude concerne le fabuleux
chantier et il est alors utile de
chercher à réduire cette incertitude en
collectant les données pertinentes pour
mieux connaître la réaction probable du
monstre vert surtout s'il nous est assez
facile d'accéder à ses données
par exemple dans ce cas serait sans
doute une bonne idée d'appeler monsieur
philip wee aa loti vos jeux pensait
offrir le fab le chantier au monstre
vert à noël mais je ne sais pas s'il va
aimer t'en penses quoi
ah mais il est déjà en train de le lire
en fête regarde je crois que ça lui
plaît bon ben voila j'ai bien fait
d'appeler tivo du coup je vais peut-être
offrir plutôt le terrain du parapluie ou
monstre vert et pour le coup dans ce cas
c'était vraiment une super idée
d'appeler thibault il a complètement
bouleversé l'état de mes connaissances
en augmentant radicalement macrez danse
en une conséquence que je pensais si
improbable que je n'avais même pas
envisagée à savoir le fait que le
monstre vert est déçu parce qu'il l'a
déjà le livre est d'ailleurs de façon
plus générale déterminer quelles
stratégies suivre pour réduire notre
incertitude est en soi un problème de
prise de décision sous incertitudes
oui parce qu'il y a de l'incertitude sur
comment est-ce qu'on va réduire
l'incertitude
il faut donc prendre en compte
l'incertitude sur la réduction de
l'incertitude pour décider comment
réduire cette incertitude
en fait le simple effort de réduction de
l'incertitude est un problème de prise
de décision qui nécessite un calcul
bézian pour ensuite améliorer notre
calcul bayésiens hashtag m'est admeta
alors on dit souvent que quand on offre
un cadeau c'est l'intention qui compte
mais alors supposer que l'intention
moralement préférable et celle qui
consiste à offrir un cadeau qui va
vraiment plaire ce qui paraît pour le
coup est vraiment une bonne intention
elle devient alors un devoir moral
d'optimiser la prise de décision d'un
cadeau à offrir et du coup en
particulier il s'agirait alors d'un
devoir moral que de passer à un peu de
temps à faire des calculs bayésiens non
mais du coup tu en fais pas c'est plus
le geste qui compte à l'intention le
monstre vert s en fout un peu les
ronettes manche est toujours pas si
c'est lire en fête
[Musique]
parfois vous avez parlé des qcm bayer a
eu beaucoup de réactions très positif
donc très content il ya david surya lui
demande s'il est possible de faire des
qcm où il ya plusieurs bonnes réponses
plutôt qu' une seule bonne réponse
en fait oui et ça correspondrait
vraiment un fait avoir un qcm avec des
questions des réponses billère en fait
faut être pour chaque proposition de
réponse
il s'agirait de répondre la probabilité
qu'on pense qu'il s'agit d'une bonne
réponse
c'est comme si en fait lorsqu'on a
plusieurs réponses qu'en fait on avait
quatre qcm à la suite oui c'était des
choix binaire oui sauf que bien sûr au
lieu de répondre oui ou non qu on met
une probabilité que la réponse est égal
à huy chine rod taylor fait la remarque
que pour optimiser la correction de
copie notamment pour les qcm ce qu'on
fait c'est qu'on m'a souvent onglet
souvent des cases en cases a et b c d ou
grise la case avec un crayon qui nous
semble être la bonne réponse c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué de donner du
coût des dénombre une façon de faire
consisterait à du coup comme ils
l'expliquent avoir une première colonne
de chiffres deuxième colonne de chiffres
il ya crise et une part aux colonnes et
du coup ça c'est une fermeture est de
décrire des probabilités à 1% près le
problème c'est que du coup ça fait
énormément de cases une manière
d'optimiser un peu plus ça ça serait de
passer en langage binaire c'est à dire
avoir des nombres avec après quelques
des 0 et des reins ça va du bien la
taille du coût de la feuille réponse
mais du coup ça nécessite des airs qui
comprennent le langage binaire donc
c'est pas non plus tip top
une autre solution sinon c'est
d'utiliser des algorithmes de
reconnaissance de chiffres du coup les
legends répondrait des chiffres et
ensuite on aura un algorithme qui lit
automatiquement les chiffres et ça
aujourd'hui c'est une technique en
machine learning ont fait énormément et
en particulier largement possible
aujourd'hui avoir des algorithmes on
utilise ces chiffres aussi bien car
demain le ferai bien sûr c'est un posera
toujours le problème des élèves qui est
à écrivent mal les chiffres et où
pirates eurent trop ce qu'ils écrivent
mais d'un côté le problème se pose
également pour le correcteur humains et
de l'autre côté
bah ça donnerait plus d'incitatifs aux
élèves de s'appliquer quand ils écrivent
le chiffre en question
j'irai me pointe un truc assez bizarre
par rapport à la notation du pratique
qui est le fait que quelqu'un qui
lorsque la réponse b
la bonne réponse répondrait dont 3 0 33
34 ans pourcentage aurait une meilleure
note que quelqu'un qu'il apprendrait 100
pour 100 000
et ça ça peut paraître assez bizarre ou
insatisfaisant en fait on peut démontrer
que la seule façon d'avoir un système de
notation qui soit promu netteté et
qu'ils fassent en sorte que la note ne
dépend uniquement de la probabilité
qu'on a assigné à la bonne réponse c'est
la seule façon d'avoir ces deux
propriétés
c'est avec l'annotation logarithmique du
coup ça peut paraître assez
insatisfaisant d'utiliser la notation
quadratique plutôt connotation
logarithmique alors un des problèmes
même si je peux surfer sur un problème
de notation logarithmique c'est que si
on met une probabilité 0 un événement et
se trouve que c'était la bonne réponse
alors du coup la notation logarithmique
nous donne moi un fini de points et ben
en fait il ya moyen de mettre juste un
seuil de supposer que en fait si la
personne a répondu 0 c'est qu'elle
voulait mettre quelque chose d'intérieur
à 10 11 0 25% et du coup de calculer la
pénalité en notation logarithmique qui
lui correspond et en fait il ya d'autres
raisons pour lesquelles j'ai tendance à
préférer la notation quadratique l'une
des raisons c'est que en fait si on
imposait notation de pratique on peut
essayer les gens mettre des priorités
dont la somme n'est pas égal à 100%
n'est pas obligé du coup de les forcer
d'avoir des priorités qui sont égales à
100% mais les étudiants devraient
découvrir qu'en fait c'est une stratégie
optimale pour eux de mettre des projets
qui dont la somme est égal à 100%
en supposant qu'ils aient des croyances
païennes et ça ça m'amène à la question
de séverine qui m'a demandé de démontrer
tout ça en fait une démonstration très
très jolie et très simple qui est
d'ailleurs un des gros intérêts dossier
de 7-9 méthode c'est que la
démonstration de la pro net au t2
la natation car l'arctique est très
simple il suffit en fait de remarquer
que l'espérance du nombre de points que
l'on marque sino créé dans son égal ap
et si on répond des réponses qui sont
égales à cul mais on peut simplement
calculé ça et il se trouve que c'est
égal à la norme l2 de paix au carré plus
la norme de paiement tu au carré est
clairement cette fonction est minimisée
lorsque qu est égal ap bref l'un des
trucs vraiment cool à connotation
pratique c'est que non seulement son
calcul est simple c'est à dire que les
gens pourront vérifier eux-mêmes que le
calcul est bon mais en plus la
démonstration de la prochaine est ôtée
est extrêmement simple également et
peut-être que si on ne la donnent jamais
les étudiants pourraient un jour se la
poser et peut-être même faire des
mathématiques sans qu'on leur demande
d'être espionnés cette vidéo d'entre
vous pour vous souhaiter un joyeux noël
et bonne nouvelle année et on se
retrouve l'année prochaine pour toujours
plus de vidéos a évidemment et encore
pas mal de vidéos et sur dubai zanni ils
sont toujours très très cool mais même
si on basculera peut-être un peu plus
sur des notions aussi d'informatique
parce que c'est encore tout comme son
ambiance informatique et benjamines on
verra ça l'année prochaine
d'ici là je vous souhaite à nouveau un
joyeux noël et j'espère que vous serez
là la prochaine fois mais l'importance
d'un risque peut être vu comme le
résultat de sa probabilité à se produire
x la magnitude de ses conséquences et un
risque existentiel poster d'une
magnétude tellement grande que même x
une petite probabilité le résultat reste
largement élevé si l'on veut qu'un
conséquentialiste me soit une théorie
morale qui puisse servir de guide dans
l'action et c'est généralement ce qu'on
attend d'une théorie moral il est clair
qu'il faut plutôt évaluer les actions à
partir de leurs conséquences attendues
puisque c'est par définition les seuls
auxquels l'agent peut se référer
lorsqu'il doit prendre sa décision pour
agir donc en général et en particulier
dans cette vidéo
lorsqu'on parle de conséquentialiste on
parle de théories selon lesquelles la
valeur morale une action dépend avant
tout des conséquences attendues de ses
actions et de ses conséquences donc sur
le monde en général